questions so obviously back then for
Survivor women needed a man advice when
they were pregnant could die and all of
these things they would perish in
today's society given Evolution given
the fact that as women we can go
together yeah but I'm I'm not saying
that isn't there a glitch between what
is actually happening and the nature of
what we have in our bodies I think
that's probably the conflict that we're
having right now glitch in what way in
the sense that women don't feel like
they need men in the most physical sense
perhaps like naturally it's very
interesting women don't feel like they
need men in a physical sense because
life is soft but it's but it's but it's
[ __ ] and it's [ __ ] because you
still need Men by proxy one and two the
second life gets difficult you very
quickly you very quickly learn how much
you need men but women don't go I'm an
independent I don't need no man because
I haven't only fans and Men be my only
fans and if anyone comes up to me I'll
call a male police officer I don't need
men shut up [ __ ] idiot of course you
do you just name your whole life is
based on [ __ ] men the roads are
driving along was paved by a man the
house you're living in was built by a
man the car you're driving who was
designed by a man your whole life
depends on men and the second anything
bad were to happen to you the second you
were physically threatened or tired
times were to get hard or War were to
start or famine or riots the first thing
you do is find a big strong man [ __ ]
yourself and throw the feminism out the
window feminism goes out the [ __ ]
window the second that the snow needs
shoveling or there's a [ __ ] broken
down car or the tire needs changing then
all that crap vanishes it's garbage and
this is the actual very interesting
thing I'll make a point here which is
gonna be canceled again but I don't give
a [ __ ] but this is the point feminism in
and of itself can't be defended any idea
the point of an idea is that it could be
defended by the people who believe in it
this is what the whole point of War
since the dawn of time it doesn't matter
if it's the Christians against the
Hindus doesn't matter if it was the
Germans against the French there were
people who had ideas and ideologies and
they're prepared to fight each other to
defend their ideology feminism is an
ideology which cannot be defended by
feminists the only people who could
defend feminism are The Men Who
subscribe to the garbage if you if all
the feminists were to get in a line and
say we want feminism and the
conservative men were to get in a line
you would learn very quickly it's
[ __ ] I had a friend in Afghanistan
when Taliban kicked America out and he
told me
the Americans were telling were telling
the girls that could go to school so
they built all these girls schools and
they put the afghanistani Defense Forces
there and they'd get funded the
Afghanistan forces to to protect these
schools you had American satellites you
had night vision goggles Taliban were
afraid to attack America leaves now you
have Afghani Defense Forces they're
basically blind they don't have
satellites anymore that don't have a
night vision whatever so now it's a real
war
the men are standing next to this girl's
school the Taliban are coming you're
some dude you're standing there and
you're looking at this girl's school
going
I don't really give a [ __ ] if girls go
to school bounce and you just and you
didn't fight so that's why they all gave
up and Taliban took over so quickly and
when I said this the girls like yeah
they should have fought for us feminism
to why don't the women fight can I ask
oh wait the women can't defend their own
[ __ ] idea you need men to defend
feminism so that's why the whole thing
is stupid so second men don't defend it
it does it just fails it's a [ __ ]
ideology it's garbage may I tell you
something now so this is the thing this
is when we assume that women perhaps
don't have the physical or even mental
ability to go to school wait wait
because this is the thing for example in
Ukraine a lot of women took up arms and
in fact I'm angolan wait wait I'm
angolan wait wait I'm angolan listen
people at home wait no worries I'll talk
about myself
let me tell you let me tell you
something this is the thing I think it's
also really like silly to assume that
for example woman because she didn't go
to school she'll not be as intelligent
as a man therefore naturally a woman is
not intelligent no it doesn't make sense
if we're not starting to normalize
equality and we want to put everybody in
the Forefront give a woman a normalizing
equality well that's what what people
are wanting then that's because let me
tell you I want to normalize the quality
people like oh feminists well actually
no equality I want respect that's video
I'm stopping you from getting respects
no I get respect
I get respected
what I think is you never know what you
want I'll tell you what I don't know
what you want you're right as a woman I
carry myself differently I actually hold
the things I have done in the fight side
for I hold it that's why when you speak
to me I don't move different I move
different to many of the girls that's
why when you talk to me and you argue
with me I don't take it you do something
and I'll tell you something a lot of
women may have the accolades to be
somebody but they're uncomfortable to
own that and the reason why then I would
like to ask you for example
um I do need a man for example to you
know procreate but other than that I'm
quite strong and I would find things
that I would find a way to protect
myself differently with that mentality
what would be the man that would be for
me then another what would you do if one
of these security guards broke into your
door
[Laughter]
okay they see you're not dead it's okay
no I'll be like this and then if not
maybe I'll kind of like be very gentle
and comply to find a way to get out okay
so if they want to come and kill me
there's not much that many people
because you make an important Point
you're talking about a quality equaling
respect the way you get respect as a
woman is by being feminine there's
nothing we can be equal and very very
different I'm not saying that where
there's not equality but you've confused
equality with the same you can be equal
with completely different things you can
have a bishop and a knight on a
chessboard they're equal in terms of
points but they do different things
right a woman can have equal respect to
a man if she is very good at being a
woman and a man gets respect for being
very good at being a man when a woman
decides she wants to act like a man or a
man wants to act like a woman that's
where all gets [ __ ] up we try to
pretend it's all the same it's not the
same men and women are good at different
things we have different strengths
different weaknesses there's nothing
wrong with accepting that there's
nothing wrong with saying I'm a woman
I'm good at X he's a man who's good at
why then we work together as a team we
have a beautiful family we're happy
forever it's only confused where you
have women who sit and go no because in
the name of equality we can fight and
work there's no [ __ ] women on the
front line in Ukraine that is silent
[ __ ] they put some chick there
dancing around doing Pokemon dances to
try and convince men to go [ __ ] die
in a ditch it's garbage if you go to the
front line of Ukraine right now you do
not see women in their makeup in their
manicures you see [ __ ] men in the
freezing cold dying you know where the
women are Dubai chilling that's where
the women are so to sit and pretend that
women are just as capable physically as
men as a [ __ ] lies delusion
descending your strongest man is
delusion you are good at all the things
you're better than men at a lot of
things but it's not the physical world
and the unfortunate reality about life
is what we're saying when I was saying
earlier that feminism goes out the
window when things get hard the harder
the world gets it the closer it gets to
the Baseline of humanity the unfortunate
Baseline of humanity is violence that's
what happens when if of all the elect
electricity were to go out and all the
police were to quit this would become a
violent place very quickly and there
would be [ __ ] zero feminists left
zero you would all need men that's the
bottom line of reality that's the bottom
line so you have to understand as a
woman to say okay I need a man who's
good at being a man but no one's saying
that we don't need men in society of
course we do we're talking about
relationships yeah you're strong but the
thing is I can live my life as a woman
and not need a man what's a woman
[Laughter]
no no saying yes we need men in society
but in relationships the only reason I
actually need you is because I want you
I don't actually need you do you know I
need you I need you to procreate yes I
agree but the things I don't need you in
my day-to-day life but wait wait wait
what if someone breaks into your house
I'll just call the police okay what if
they don't come what if the average
place in the US it takes like 50 and
give them everything in the fifth in the
US it takes like 15. that is for them to
get that's not realistic that's okay
these two guys in your in your house
what are you doing that's not realistic
I've not had any man break into my house
on a day today
I know what you're saying but the point
is this the point is
when we're talking about feminism as a
whole feminism as a whole demonizes men
and you just said you just sat and said
besides procreation I don't need a man
in my life I can go to a male mechanic
or call a male police officer they're
men so it's it
I agree I agree of course we need you of
course so you're talking about being
with a man because you want to so my
question to you is why would you want to
be with him why would a man want to be
with you because they're sexy like
obviously
I love men no I love them I like it but
it's not all about Dick what I'm trying
to say in a good relationship right one
that works there's Blue Jobs and there's
pink jobs right and that's the problem
that women have got oh gee they don't
want to be doing no pink jobs
we're talking
a man in a relationship be
on there which companionship
romantic love things that you can't get
by yourself technically you want to go
on dates with him it's not about I need
someone to fix my car like go to a
mechanic You're Not Safe call the police
what about a father to your kids
you can be around I definitely want that
these are the stuff this is the reason
I agree wait wait wait it's not it's not
that you want it you need it I agree and
these are the stuff that I need in a man
but it's like at the end of the day it's
not like I completely need you I want
the whole but the whole point is if the
lights went out tomorrow you would need
a man
why do we have like women useless
I'm saying if if the lights went out
tomorrow you would need someone to
protect you you will of course in a
society not my boyfriend half of my ex
is can't even do anything
that's actually another problem a lot of
men can't do much you know what I mean
not everybody's stage in this day and
age guys can't even fit a tired
I have to do one at a time can I just
say something
this is why you can't blame all men for
your poor choices
you can't say I'm talking to both of you
because you're not saying yeah my man
can't do this my man can't do that what
and you want to settle down why would
you go and choose a man
that can't do these things that you
wanted them to do because my man could
do all the blue I need a man because
most men grow up with a PlayStation
instead most men grow up with
PlayStations
no that's the truth speak for yourself
speak for yourself
my boyfriend you know what I need a
father to my children I don't need
something right
she needs a farmer for her children
right so she's gonna go out there right
and you're gonna buy your child an
electric car you're gonna go and buy
your child a bicycle Who the hell's
gonna play the bicycle and fix the
electric car who doesn't do it you've
got YouTube I know how to do these
things
yourself go and get some sperm done or
something because you obviously don't
need a man that's the future the future
for who no Society
let me finish talking right now you can
you got a man right and you've been busy
all day right and you're in your bed at
one o'clock in the morning and your man
comes in with all of his friends
and said oh babes all the friends are
here they're hungry what you gonna do
yeah I'll cook for my man I
am I even start cooking
National eggs it's everything it's not
just about cookies
I have a question are you virgin you're
traditionally virgin are you a virgin
I said in that aspect I'm not gonna
comment on me being a virgin or not but
what I'm gonna say is every every human
being should be able to cook she's
enough she's a hybrid of tradition and
modernization that survives you know I
need to cook to survive can I can I ask
me to take something right as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible